more and more there's this interest in
having bigger eyes and that's why there
are a lot of people in Asia who do
surgery to actually get a double eyelid
[Music]
so we're going to get double eyelids
photoshopped on pictures of ourselves
double eyelids are when you have a fold
or crease on the skin of your eyelid and
it causes your eye to look slightly
larger generally speaking a lot of
Asians do not have double eyelids
whereas a lot of Western Caucasian or
other folks have double eyelids I'm not
really sure how it got to be that Asians
and you know Koreans especially were so
fixated on this very particular look
everyone there their ideal beauty
standard is to have the bigger eyes the
idea of double eyelids definitely did
entice me I just didn't ever actually
want to go through with it I felt like I
was bullied for having small eyes
keypoint you with just offhand Lee
suggests surgery to me they offered it
as gifts this graduation presents and
it's just like so hard to keep up with
it didn't really help that my family my
aunts my mom just told me that I would
look prettier with the double eyelid
surgery and that one day I should get it
I tried a lot of different things to get
that double eyelid without getting the
actual surgery and a ton of my friends
have actually gone to Korea and come
back with the surgery done I just wanted
to look like what my family and my
friends wanted me to look like I think
very clearly I knew that was different
definitely there were jokes too where
people would say things about like your
eyes being smaller or things like that
so it is what it is
[Music]
I'm kind of shaking right now
like I actually got surgery done or
something I'm shaking ready oh my god
first of all I can't even recognize
myself I think it's because like I'm so
unaccustomed to seeing this and I'm so
used to the way that my eyes look and
honestly I think I prefer the way my
eyes look now versus the Photoshop
version hmm I mean I know deep down
they'll never get the surgery but
knowing that this is a possibility I
thought it would be more different but
the changes and the two pictures are
pretty subtle I'm extra conflicted hmm
seeing my eyes fit more of the
westernized Beauty ideal it's I feel a
little uncomfortable that this is what I
need to look like in order to fit that
beauty standard it makes me really sad
that I like put myself down so much and
then I listen to so many people around
me but I'm realizing now that I don't
want that and I don't think that that's
for me you know you just have to embrace
your beauty in your own way if you want
to change yourself I would do it because
you truly want to and not because
society tells you to I think this is
just a really good reminder for all of
us that sure there are things that
sometimes we feel insecure about but
really there's a lot more work inside I
think that we need to do I've just
become so much more comfortable with
this that this makes me uncomfortable
and this makes me just remember
everything that I tried to be that I'm
inherently not and I'm okay with that
I'm okay with what I am right now
[Music]